oh apparently i just can't vortex
manipulator my way off this
topic
for anybody who is sick of me talking
about this
i get it and i'm sorry i'm sick of me
talking about this but this stuff eats
away at me
and sometimes the best way for me to
sort out how i
feel is to talk it through
because i've got really mixed feelings
about where things stand right now and
again a bit like the last time i talked
about
john barrowman and his behavior on set
i'm actually going to be focused more on
the conversation around
it than the man's activities directly
but
just to be sure that everyone's up to
speed one
john barrowman who played captain jack
harkness on doctor who amongst
many other things is fairly well known
at this point for
exposing himself in a playful prankster
way
not in a way that is generally
documented as being in any way predatory
but
i think it's hard to say that it
wouldn't be
severely inappropriate but this has been
a known fact for some time
it came up in conversation due to
uh numerous allegations against his
doctor who
co-star noel clark now
i'll circle back on that briefly but
with within that conversation when
looking through
old footage of noah clark which is
something the internet likes to do once
someone who is accused of the kinds of
things noel clark is accused of
they'd like to go back through and go
were their warning signs were there
early indicators and what ended up
circling around again as a result of
that was a panel
from 2015 where noel clark talked about
barron's tendency to
whip his junk out and suddenly that put
bearman in the conversation
at the same time so again even though
this wasn't new information about
bearman
a new conversation or at least a
conversation on a much grander scale
than it ever happened before
then started occurring
next up since the last time i did a
video
i have not been made aware of any new
uh allegations really i am gonna touch
on a couple of things related to that
but
there isn't like new stuff out about
john berryman really
not not not that i was made aware of
and he has largely been keeping his head
down which honestly is probably the
smartest thing he could do right now
however there have been repercussions
two of them the first being the
interactive experience doctor who
related experience called time fracture
was going to have an element and an
appearance by
john behrman that is no longer going to
be part of that
secondly big finish which is not owned
by the bbc to be clear but holds an
awful lot of bbc licenses
including doctor who and torchwood
canceled plans for
future torchwood related audio
adventures
that bearman was going to appear on now
he's already appeared in big finish
quite a bit up to this point but
they canceled any future ones and that's
kind of where i want to pick up for the
most part
is talking about the consequences that
are
being met right now and my very
mixed feelings about all of this
now again full disclosure i'm trying to
be as impartial as i possibly can
honestly i can't be i met john barrowman
once
i had a wonderful experience interacting
with him
it's hard for me to shake that it really
is but i'm doing my best
secondly i said i'd circle back onto
noel clark
really really quickly and i hate i
despise the fact that the conversation
about these two men
have been intertwined because quite
frankly the stuff that bearman is
accused of
while not okay did a whole video talking
about why it's not okay
and people saying oh it's not a big deal
like
please don't do that but it is really
frustrating that the two have been in
conjunction and i'm really frustrated
with myself that i end up talking about
john barrowman more but the reason
is there isn't actually that much of a
conversation to be had about noel clark
no clark unless you are going to make an
accusation that
dozens of women have organized a
conspiracy to take down
one guy who is semi-known
in uh in the industry and not
particularly well known outside of
doctor who once you leave the uk
no i have a hard time buying that that's
a conspiratorial narrative i will never
buy into
but unless you're going to that degree
there really isn't a conversation to be
had about no clark
the things he is accused of by the
number of people he is accused by
and the amount of veracity that has been
given like
people who have tried to defend him have
tried to say things like
look there isn't evidence yet it's just
people no there is evidence
anyone who said that hasn't actually
looked at the accusations or the
reporting on those accusations from
journalists who have looked
into those accusations and have
highlighted the ones with the most
veracity and evidence
to them but again the result of that is
there isn't really a conversation to be
had about noel
clark toss them up chuck them in the bin
because what's gone on with barrowman
has been much
muddier in terms of his action or at
least muddy or versus
what went on with no clark and in terms
of the conversation that's been
happening there is more to actually talk
about
so do not think that the fact that i am
now on my third video bringing up john
barrowman when i only brought up no
clark once
means that i think bearman is the bigger
problem or anything like that i
absolutely do not
but there's more to talk about i really
have
nothing new to say about noel clark i
absolutely
nothing i'm done with them
behrman it's it's different it's weirder
it's messier
so there's a number of reasons why
actually seeing planned projects
cancelled makes me
uneasy and let me be very clear if you
think the word
canceled culture is about to come out of
my mouth
then you clearly are new to this channel
and don't know me at all
however the way in which
he is being made to be held responsible
feels off and weird and
a little wrong to me now again
i'm not saying his behavior was okay i'm
not saying his behavior should be
consequence free
but it's not that clear cut because as i
said at the start
none of this is new information so i
made the comparison previously
between john berryman and
james gunn where they are being punished
and held responsible for stuff from a
significant amount of time of go
i'm actually going to kind of decouple
that comparison for a couple of reasons
uh the first being despite the last time
i did a video on john bearman the most
recent incident that i could find dating
from 2008
there have been some reportings of
things more recent than that although
not in as
much detail but you can find interviews
with his co-stars on things like
arrow where he played a recurring
villain where they seem to indicate he
was up to
those kinds of jokes john barrowman gets
away with more stuff
than i've ever seen anyone get away with
just because
there's never a filter not as many
specific details have come out
but it does at the very least cloud the
idea that after 2008 when
um julie gardner said he was officially
reprimanded
the idea that he did nothing wrong since
then it's now at the very
least cloudy there have been some other
things there was a journalist who wrote
a piece
um talking about how john bearman
treated and kind of cat called him in a
very aggressive manner
i don't want to put too much focus on
that though because
the article actually didn't cite any
dates
that i could find it only referred to
vaguely as before me too but that's a
wide swath of time
so i don't find that particularly
helpful but my point being the
the idea of he has done absolutely
nothing like this since 2008
i have a hard time buying that he
doesn't seem to be as have been
prolific about it uh as he was prior to
that but
i i don't feel comfortable making that
claim that he's done nothing since 2008
anymore and the other reason i want to
decouple the comparison to james gunn
is that with james gunn at the time he
was
basically being dog piled by online
elements who dug up
a bunch of old tweets and very off-color
very inappropriate jokes which he had
actually already addressed and since
disowned
now while it was certainly stuff that
the people
at disney where he was initially let go
and wasn't permitted to
uh work on the third guardians of the
galaxy film he's now back and will do
that
but when they let him go like they
should have been aware of his
past professional history as kind of an
edge lord professionally the man wrote
for troma for crying out loud
so that was kind of a like did they not
know who they were hiring
now in the case of john berman it is a
little bit different or at least in
regards to this whole thing because
with james gunn unless you were a really
deep cut fan of his work
you probably didn't know about those
kinds of jokes that he had a tendency to
make back in the day
and a lot of marvel fans wouldn't have
because they would have come to
guardians of the galaxy as fans of
marvel
not necessarily as fans of james gunn
but barreman's activities have been well
known
on set with doctor who and by the fandom
his co-stars would tell stories like the
highlighted clip came from that
panel in 2015 but his co-stars have been
telling stories like that
for years he's been telling stories like
that
the fandom has known
yet only now is punishment being met out
so it's not like a case of oh
we didn't realize he was like this
no all it would take is a very
preliminary
basic search of any behind-the-scenes
antics to come up with at least a couple
of stories about barriman and if you've
ever seen him or anyone talk about him
at any kind of con or panel or anything
this would have come up
now casual fans of doctor who okay maybe
they didn't know but anyone who like
takes the fandom even a slight degree of
seriously
we knew we all knew
yet only now is it time for consequences
and again i'm not necessarily saying
that there should be no consequences
but here's a big part of why it feels
weird and wrong to me
because now going well
we're not going to have him in future
doctor who stuff
it feels to me like it is the
franchise as a whole and a lump in bbc
with
big finish anyone who's directly
involved with the franchise at this
point
and the fandom abdicating their own
responsibility in their own complicity
in this because like i said
this was not new information
it's not an expose it doesn't
bear a comparison to something like bill
cosby or harvey weinstein
which were open secrets within the
industry
and that absolutely is a condemnation of
that industry and of hollywood as a town
but general public didn't know that
fans of those people's work or things
they produced
i don't know who was really a fan of
harvey weinstein but people who were
fans of the things that their names were
on didn't know that
fans knew this about john barrowman so
it's not a sudden revelation oh he was
like this and we didn't know no we knew
we knew and we were
okay with it now i don't doubt that
certain individuals were not okay with
it be they people on the set or
fans but collectively as a fandom
it was given a pass
and now it's not and again to be clear
i've said it already repeatedly but the
behavior was not appropriate and i'm not
defending his behavior
i am however saying that it feels very
much like
the fandom and the people behind doctor
who is a property
want no part of the responsibility of
the fact
that he was allowed to do that and
everybody laughed about it and very
little was done
now at this point we do have word from
julie garner about
the official reprimand that she gave him
but that's the only person notable power
who has said anything about trying to
rein in his behavior
and the fact that we're getting you know
vague or granted but stories off the set
of arrow
there is a culture at play
that has allowed him to believe
that this kind of behavior was okay
and punishing him in specific now
and acting like well we dealt with the
problem
and while i think there is a
conversation to be had and like i i
linked to the video already i did kind
of have it about the appropriateness or
inappropriateness of his behavior
the conversation that isn't going on
right now that really should be
at the very least i'm not seeing it
happen on any kind of scale
is the fact that the fandom wrote it off
either laughed about it or didn't talk
about it that the atmosphere on set
let it go on and even
if i take julie gardner at her word that
in 2008 she
officially reprimanded him that's still
several years worth of production where
he was showing up
in doctor who related material doing
this kind of thing
before he was reprimanded in any
official capacity
there's a culture on set there's a
culture in the industry there is a
culture within fandom
that let this be okay
until it was brought back up
at a time when yeah i know that behavior
really kind of isn't okay and now we're
going to
punish in a rather delayed fashion
but not confront
our culpability or that the bbc
and the franchise holders are not
confronting
their culpability and the other aspect
of this that makes me uncomfortable that
i'm not going to sink as much time
into but i am seeing
has to do with the way that people are
saying
well if we're going to punish noel clark
we
have to punish john barrowman again
equating the two when
no no and that's something
that i've seen and i have a very hard
time believing is being deployed in good
faith
because anyone who's going to make that
claim refuses to look at specifics and
look at nuance and i have said it before
and i will keep saying it nothing
is ever always
things have specifics things have nuance
not everything should be treated
as if it's the exact same thing when it
is clearly evidently not
related yes unfortunately in both cases
oh
absolutely but the same thing to be
treated the same way
no so the way at which it seems to have
been concluded that
john barrowman needs to be punished
again
feels really weird to me and i'm not
saying he does not deserve
some form of punishment i'm not even
necessarily going to say that these
cancellations are bad ideas
and i will also add that from the
perspective of the bbc
and or big finish it's just a pr move
like i said none of this information is
new to them
but suddenly it's bad pr so let's just
let's nix that for right now and maybe
if it ever quiets down it'll come back
but from their perspective that's all
this is this this is only a pr move
but from within the fandom and seeing
the fights go on
we were okay with it
and if we're going to say that he was
wrong
then we have to own up and say that we
were wrong
and i'll include myself in that when i
went and saw him at
terrificon he told a story on stage at
his
panel performance thing i don't know
what to call it it was fun
but he told a story about holding a kiss
with
i believe it was james marsters
for longer than was originally planned
he asked the director not to call cut so
that he could make it last longer
and i laughed and i need to own up to
that
because that behavior isn't appropriate
that's extended physical
intimate contact beyond the parameters
of
what should have gone on for that shoot
for that scene for their professional
job
strictly for the purposes of john
berman's entertainment
and he would probably claim hopefully
for the entertainment of others
but it was inappropriate
i laughed i didn't think more about it
and i need to come to terms with that
collectively all of us
need to come to terms with our own
culpability and complicity
in his behavior and his belief that it
was okay
because if every time he performed these
acts on set
if the majority of people laughed and
maybe he failed to realize it was
nervous laughter
i don't know it wasn't there and if
every time he retells these stories in
front of an audience
he gets applause and laughter validation
then we helped perpetuate the behavior
to some degree
and i need to see more of us having
that conversation with ourselves and
each other
if we're also going to hold him
responsible
now are we responsible for his behavior
no
no we're not but there was absolutely a
culture that validated and reinforced
and
applauded literally applauded
what it was he did and we need to
take our own ownership of that do i
think it's
the right thing to do to cut berryman
out of
the doctor who property and just
not have him appear any further
i don't know i don't feel comfortable
saying it's
the wrong thing or the right thing all i
can say
is it makes me
feel weird watching it happen
knowing how public this information was
i don't have a definitive conclusion i
don't know what the best thing
to do is in terms of his involvement
moving forward i honestly
do not know and maybe this is the best
thing
i don't have a conclusion yet
but i am asking myself questions
that i hope more people
will start to also ask of themselves
because this doesn't happen in a vacuum
especially not
in a case like berman where
we all knew so those are my
ultimately inconclusive thoughts but i i
really had to again just expel from my
head
this stuff because it it needles me
and if i don't get it out it's gonna
keep bugging me
but what are your thoughts on all this
whatever your thoughts are
please be as polite as possible about me
about john bearman that's not me saying
you have to approve of him
but please restrain from name calling
and personal attacks
i don't like having that in my comments
no matter what side of the argument
you're on
but if you can keep it respectful
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments
let's talk about it i have a patreon
which is how i pay my bills and it's how
i keep this operation up and running
there are rewards for every tier from
getting to see the docket early and vote
on potential topics
to access to a discord server your name
in the credits and
more than that there's also the option
for youtube memberships which
nets you some different rewards in some
cases but you don't have to
do any of that the likes share subscribe
those things help me out
i've been doing a little bit better the
algorithm has been totally bearing me
lately so
that every little bit helps it really
does but even that
i am not going to insist that you do it
because at the end of the day you're the
council
i just run the meetings and until next
time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye